this is where the advantages of starting
to think about visually they start to
stack off okay tell me what should I do
first sign of working suggestions yeah I
can't factorizing and it's nice and neat
what's the factorization obviously very
good okay now that's enough that's it
that's enough algebraic working that I
can now appeal to my ground from this I
can see there are two roots one in four
okay so I'm just gonna mark them in okay
there you go that's all I need to solve
this inequality okay now I look
carefully at what kind of boundaries
I've got right so I'm greater than or
equal to zero so I'm looking at above
yes looking about soon now and I may
actually go ahead and do this properly
right
my solution here is gonna be next values
my solutions in X values so therefore
I'm looking along this number line okay
that's where I'm actually gonna have
solutions one of the pipes that
correspond to above well including the
boundary I'm here to the right should be
on the line sorry
and then I hear through the left and of
course I know what these values now
being that the solution to this
inequality represents two completely
separate regions less than 1 less than
or equal to 1 greater than any reason
for it is worth writing this as two
separate algebraic employees like so X
is less than n to the 1 or X is greater
than or equal to 4 okay yes
okay good question so the question was
if I didn't do this if I did this would
I get it wrong okay and the answer is no
dependent on what you write because
actually this this process again it's
the mechanism we use but it's not the
answer okay so it's my it's for me
really this is for me so if you did this
if you did these dots that's fine like
and then you wrote down this okay
because you correctly represent the
correct path yeah yeah that's totally
fine that's fine
to be honest I'm doing all of this extra
stuff because I'm trying to illustrate
my brain to you right but if it was just
me and my brain and this is my endpoint
right I don't need to do any of these
markings because I've seen this question
so many times before and I'm familiar
with the fact that what I'm looking for
is the part of the crab lab of the
y-axis and including the axis so you
don't need to make any markings at all
so long as you arrive at this conclusion
okay now it's worth saying that I'll do
it in red some people insist on taking
these values just make sure I get this
right and writing them like this okay
now this is look at it for a second okay
when you look at the directions of all
of the inequality signs how would you
break Li it's right algebraic please
right it just happens to be a really bad
way of writing it okay because can you
see what's happening two things are
happening number one you're writing
inequality signs in the wrong direction
okay because when you go from left to
right left to right we're going from
less up to smaller and you're going from
1 to 4 but actually like the 1 to 4
matches but your inequality signs not
managed okay secondly you're trying to
represent two different parts as one
which they are not okay and so then you
run the risk of actually confusing it
with this which would be the answer to
the opposite question which is this
little spine here
okay so please please please don't write
it like this to see advantage of seeing
it visually if it's two things write it
as two things support okay